affectionately coined the mother of
beauty taddy Westbrook is a YouTuber and
professional makeup artist with a
passionate fan Community well of course
she's a beauty Creator first she's also
notorious for heated YouTube drama most
notably her online Feud with James
Charles that gained her millions of
subscribers it was spicy that's for sure
so spicy that it prompted a year-long
Hiatus from her Channel
I'll be back but For Better or Worse
tatty's back and now with a newfound
passion for nutrition as evidenced by
her controversial q a video I was making
myself sick I know I say this often but
this could be the understatement of the
Year there is a lot here to unpack hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
we'll be taking a look at YouTuber and
makeup artist taddy Westbrook's video I
was making myself sick and you can pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as I will be discussing a wide
range of very restrictive behaviors and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and don't forget
to follow me on Tick Tock and Instagram
at Abby's kitchen before we get into
today's video we're going to play
another round of Abby's daily hunger
crush and combo this time featuring ice
cream because sometimes I just need my
fix so we've got our ice cream going
down I'm adding in some various frozen
berries that I just thought out
got some blueberries blackberries
cherries all the goodies
um
then I've got a little almond butter
going down and I've got my white
chocolate berry bilbar granola bar you
guys know I love these because they
taste like chocolate because they're
made with real chocolate the white
chocolate specifically she just hits
different this bar has 15 grams of
protein so it's a great topper for my
ice cream along with the fiber in the
berries and the healthy fats in the
almond butter so if you guys want to try
build bar for yourself check out my link
in the description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
[Music]
um
now you guys were all up in my DMs
requesting that I review this video and
trust me it is so Rife with
misinformation that I could barely fit
it all into like one succinct video so
get your Wellness Bingo cards ready
folks oh my God bingo
let's dive in this is just my story of
my up and down from having been much
heavier to having been so skinny I never
had an issue with any eating disorder or
anything like that so I want to make
that clear this has been kind of a
frustration through my life to be up and
down with my hormones and my weight and
we're going to talk about how I have now
landed in a place where I feel like yes
yes like I can sleep at night I am
gaining actual muscle I am eating like a
queen I enjoy the food that I eat it is
delicious I feel so truly nourished that
I wake up I'm excited for the food that
I eat I'm excited to move my body I
don't feel achy and painy and foggy I
kind of feel like this is basically how
almost all sales pitches for
pseudoscience diets start off but I'm
gonna try to keep an open mind here
let's take a look at some of taddy's
controversial claims now I'm a little
more aware of microplastics in this past
year just kind of going on this deep
dive what I want to purify out of my
system what I think is disrupting
hormones or potentially causing other
issues so with water I think filtering
is a really really important thing to do
I do not drink tap water other things
like byproducts of other Pharmaceuticals
chlorine arsenic you may consider
getting a filter now while we still need
high quality human research to really
understand the mechanisms in in full we
do know that microplastic consumption is
a growing Public Health concern due to
its potential hormone disrupting effects
now it's also true that much of our tap
water today has been shown to contain
small amounts of microplastics but when
researchers put contaminated water
samples through a water filter that
could potentially remove particles as
small as 2.5 microns 41.5 percent of the
samples were still contaminated this was
basically confirmed by consumer Labs
reports when they tested popular water
filter pictures and found a wide range
in microplastic reduction in one case
the pitcher actually increased
microplastic particles by 1200 percent
as for chlorine arsenic fluoride and
other compounds found in small amounts
in some tap water different types of
filters will remove different types of
contaminants so whether or not you opt
for one will ultimately depend on your
priorities and goals but I also want to
remind you that at least in most
jurisdictions tap water is still
completely fine to drink the United
States has very strict regulations on
tap water to ensure that levels of these
contaminants are well under safe limits
so assume your jurisdiction or country
has safe regulated water any tap water
is going to be better than consuming
less water out of fear it's also worth
pointing out that there are microplastic
particles in almost everything we come
into contact with including healthy
fruits and vegetables so if you do want
to reduce your consumption I would focus
on reducing Foods or drink that are less
essential for good health than let's say
water things like single-use water
bottles storage wraps plastic containers
skin care products Etc if you've been
with me for a long time you understand
how devastated I was to find out that I
had a gluten intolerance I absolutely
don't think gluten is great for you
um first of all unless you are diagnosed
with Celiac or a sensitivity to gluten
there is no quality research just that
gluten is inherently not great for
everyone in fact most gluten-free foods
are likely less great for the masses in
general because they are usually lower
in Iron fiber B vitamins magnesium and
selenium compared to their gluten-filled
counterparts second there is no
recommended methods of testing for
gluten sensitivity or intolerance you'll
see lots of like blood spot or
inflammation or food intolerance IGG
tests marketed online but none of them
are validated or accurate in fact all
the major health authorities recommend
against using them the only way to
diagnose gluten intolerance is by
exclusion if you test for celiac and
it's negative and you remove gluten from
your diet and you feel better yes there
is a chance that you may be gluten
intolerant now it could also
alternatively be something else in the
gluten containing foods like wheat or
fodmaps but in tatty's case specifically
we know that endometriosis and celiac
disease are often in intrinsically
linked likely because they are both
inflammatory in nature and it's common
for autoimmune disorders to overlap now
a lot of folks never get a proper
diagnosis for celiac because you have to
consume a lot of gluten to properly do
the test and this can be very
uncomfortable for a lot of folks who are
struggling with their digestion
regardless of the specific diagnosis
here if Daddy feels better going
gluten-free it totally makes sense to
keep it up but please let's stop
perpetuating misinformation about
perfectly nutritious Foods I have heard
that through the fermentation process
with sourdough that I might be able to
get away with eating sourdough homemade
products so it is true that the
fermentation process of sourdough bread
partially breaks down gluten making it
easier to tolerate in folks with gluten
sensitivity however this does not make
it gluten free so if we're talking
Celiac it's still a no if we're talking
mild sensitivity then it might be a more
tolerated choice I now have my
suspicions that seed oils were
definitely also a factor in how I was
digesting they're very inflammatory
influencers love to harp on the
inflammatory properties of seed oils
because of their omega-6 content and
while there is some research to confirm
that too much omega-6 in the diet may
increase inflammation the larger body of
high quality evidence suggests that
omega-6 fats do not have a significant
Effect one 2012 systematic review even
looked at the effects of omega-6s on
inflammatory markers and found no strong
link to suggest that it increased
inflammation what we can say though is
that most of us are getting more omega-6
fats than omega-3 fats from the Western
diet which throws off the ideal four to
one ratio for reducing inflammation
interestingly one of the most commonly
demonized seed oils canola has actually
a very favorable two to one ratio of
omega-6s to omega-3 fats along with very
heart healthy monounsaturated fats so
bottom line focus on getting fat and oil
variety and diversity to get the most
diverse array of fatty acids in your
diet next and I also feel like
glyphosate in a lot of the um well in
all wheat products which is a weed
killer all right let's do it Wellness
culture loves a good headline and the
idea of a serial killer AKA carcinogen
in our oatmeal or Cheerios always hits
home hard I think Life's a scary
reputation can ultimately be linked back
to some older studies linking glyphosate
to some potential cancer risks in
agricultural farmers who had the highest
levels of direct exposure to the
herbicide however the vast majority of
research in this area has actually found
no significant risk at all but let's
just say theoretically that there is a
risk of inhaling large amounts of
glyphsid in the field every single day
at work this will never be the same as
just like eating a bowl of Cheerios we
would need to consume hundreds of
servings of these foods with glyphosate
residues to even meet the acceptable
daily intake of one milligram per
kilogram of body weight in fact food
science babe did the leg work for us and
calculated that you would need to
consume
2355 servings of oatmeal every day to
meet even the defined safe amount the
truth is glyphosate is one of the most
extensively studied chemicals and has
long been considered one of the safest
herbicides on the market research has
consistently shown that the Trace
Amounts of exposure to glyphosate from
food is not a significant risk to our
health and when we are exposed to these
residues from food it actually does not
even accumulate in the body and is
completely eliminated within 24 hours of
exposure so as is the case with most
chemical exposures in the food system
the dose makes the poison and the dose
in this case is pretty low I am
suspecting now that I have an issue with
how my body handles oxalates and
basically that is a vegetables defense
system that leeches nutrients from your
body hard to digest can create crystals
in the body but you have to eat your
greens but for me removing them from my
diet and Hiking up the fat and the
protein has been the biggest win of my
life oh dear Lord are we going carnivore
now
bone marrow is amazing okay let's clear
this mess up together oxalates which are
an anti-nutrient found in plant foods do
not Leach nutrients from the body but
rather they reduce the absorption of
calcium specifically as for the clean
that they create crystals in the body
this is really only for those who are
already prone to calcium oxalate kidney
stones who are advised to limit their
intake of oxalate containing foods for
everyone else oxalates can be safely
consumed with no issues and we can even
reduce the oxalate content of foods
through cooking and again Tatty is only
speculating that this is an issue for
her if she feels better eliminating
vegetables it's much more likely related
to their FODMAP load since endometriosis
also tends to be associated with IBS IBS
or not we actually would never recommend
people eliminate all vegetables this may
temporarily reduce some digestive
symptoms but it would likely wipe out a
lot of our beneficial gut bacteria which
would only worsen gut health long term
fiber is absolutely key for supporting a
healthy gut and vegetables and grains
are some of the best sources of that
fiber I don't want to say I'm carnivore
but I'm definitely animal based I do
still have some vegetables protein High
saturated fat good sugars from fruits I
eat a lot of honey maple vegetables here
and there I eat a lot of eggs I feel
that eating raw cheese and doing Dairy
has been incredibly beneficial for my
overall health there are just some
things you can't get from Plants I'm
sorry didn't we go over this with
carnivore MD if you guys miss me taking
that down check out my video right here
but while we're still getting some carbs
fiber and antioxidants from fruit we're
talking about severely limited food
options the reason she feels better
eating animal base isn't because of the
animal food she's added but it's because
she's cut out so many possible triggers
even though most of them probably aren't
triggering at all I also want to note
that there is no clinical benefit to to
eating more saturated fat it doesn't
appear that there's a major harm in
saturated fats like we used to think as
I discussed in my video right here but
we do know that replacing some saturated
fats with unsaturated fats or whole
grains is healthier than adding more
saturated fat we also have some evidence
linking red meat consumption with
endometriosis risk so generally speaking
here this does not seem like a super
smart plan ditto with the raw milk I
mean please do not drink raw milk raw
milk is responsible for dozens of
foodborne illness outbreaks every year
and its potential health benefits will
never outweigh the risk next
intermittent fasting I think can work
really well for men I think for women or
hormones are so up and down and they
move around in the different parts of
the month and I think that it can be
really hard on your hormones so for me I
don't intermittent fast this for me is a
huge sign of how that I wake up in the
morning and I'm hungry so I have a whole
video on the impact of intermittent
fasting on hormones which you can watch
right here but in short intermittent
fasting is thought to potentially
increase the risk of menstrual
dysfunction and hormonal irregularities
because it increases the likelihood of
going under the critical threshold of
energy availability in simpler words
because intermittent fasting often
results in eating fewer calories less
frequently it can put you in a chronic
state of low energy available for
hormonal regulation now this effect will
obviously depend on how what and how
much you eat plus if and when you are
exercising so intermittent fasting can
be very safe and even beneficial for a
lot of folks but we do know that the
reproductive system is very sensitive to
energy imbalances and if we're doing too
long a fast while also in a calorie
deficit it can potentially do some harm
saying I cut out Starbucks because I
really realize the kind of milk they use
I I want control of the quality that I
was putting in the coffee I won't
control the quality of the coffee beans
coffee beans are almost always sprayed
with glyphosate so in the effort of
removing that and kind of limiting mold
exposure so there is some concern that
coffee contains mycotoxins from mold if
coffee beans are not stored properly
however as I discussed in my coffee
video right here well research has found
small amounts of mycotoxins in some
coffee beans the amounts are
significantly below what is considered
safe for human consumption in fact once
that he found that drinking four cups of
coffee only provided two percent of the
total amount of toxin exposure that is
considered to be safe just two percent
ultimately the dose makes the poison and
you would have to drink an excessive and
clinically very dangerous amount of
coffee to experience any adverse effects
it's also worth noting that we are
exposed to mycotoxins from food that we
eat every single day including nuts
fruits whole grains spices chocolate and
even human breast milk and we also
discussed the whole glyphic thing it's
not a major concern I think that um the
bioavailability of animal protein is
just like next level I feel like I was
eating a lot of foods that just weren't
sticking like your body just doesn't
want to accept it it can have so many
grams of one particular nutrient but if
your body doesn't know what to do with
it well good luck when you eat eggs
organs when you're eating meat you are
actually eating something the body knows
what to do with what's something sounds
vague and made up like this it's because
it probably is
why you always lying yes it's true that
certain nutrients like iron are more
bioavailable from animal sources
compared to plant-based sources but the
body is well equipped to digest and
absorb nutrients from All Foods assuming
you don't have of an intolerance allergy
sensitivity or gut disorder that impairs
the digestion of that specific food
there is no evidence or even
hypothetical reason why your body would
know what to do with organ meat but not
know what to do with broccoli folks our
bodies are smart as oh this is this is a
really good one did your diet change
help your Endo symptoms like my hormones
are in such a better place so to bring
it all together here's my professional
opinion on why taddy likely feels her
best self on this flexible carnivore
diet for one by eliminating vegetables
and gluten containing foods she's
completely limited her exposure to high
FODMAP Foods a small number of which may
be exacerbating her digestive symptoms
however this would be far from the best
long-term diet for endometriosis
management fiber and antioxidants and
vegetables in whole grains actually help
to reduce our estrogen levels and
inflammation so so these are often
considered integral components of a
healthy Endo diet and as I already
mentioned excessive red meat intake is
also associated with higher
endometriosis risk I imagine that part
of the rationale for the red meat is for
healthy iron levels which is another
common endometriosis diet recommendation
but we can still see this benefit
without as much risk by including things
like Fish seafood poultry and eggs plus
plant-based sources paired with vitamin
C rich fruits and veg a good diet for
endometriosis IBS and other inflammatory
conditions should ultimately be highly
individualized and will depend on the
unique triggers of that person but we
would never suggest cutting out full
food groups to find relief especially
when those foods have so many
anti-inflammatory properties so please
if you're struggling on your own health
journey I get that it can be so tempting
to see a video like this and just follow
suit but a beauty mom is not not a
dietitian so please be cautious Whose
advice you follow and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today I would love to hear your thoughts
on who or what you'd like to see me
review next subscribe to the channel and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]